Jenny first question here in the front
ok how are you good how are you Janie
McCauley from ap the Warriors and and
the MBA have both suspended the man who
shoved you ended up being a minority
owner the team and everybody on the
Warriors is crediting you for your the
way you handled that situation
a day later can you kind of take us
through it and do you appreciate the
reaction quickly from from all sides I
want to thank the Warriors for the
statement they issued and an NBA also
you know it's just you know what I
leaves about and protecting the players
and like I said last night there's no
room for it on our game for that you
know in that situation I don't think
I've I could have handled it any better
you know I'm glad I did what I did and
understanding that you know things could
have been a lot different if I reacted a
different way or if I did something or
put my hands on them or did anything in
that nature but the support I've gotten
from fellow players League has been
unbelievable
with that be set with that being said
you know I think you know s'mores should
be done you know I don't think he's not
a good look for the ownership group that
they have and and and I know Joel a-cup
those guys are great gobs the ownership
that they have that I know they're
unbelievable
a guy like that showing his true class
and he shouldn't be a part of our league
it's just no place for that Jeff's
standing on the right chef Soviet USA
today cows that's it with a little
sideways last night could you confirm
what the guy said to you to go Blake
yourself is that accurate yeah multiple
times
in that situation you were just talking
about how did you keep your cool
understand at the moment my team needed
me understand that there there are
plenty of fans and kids and in the world
watching this game and me being a
having kids myself and I'm gonna grow
man you know I'm you know my kids have
could always go back and see that and
anywhere other situation if it wasn't
you know in this situation things may
have been they probably would have been
done differently handled differently by
me but understanding that I have two
young children and you know to being
able to hold myself to a certain
standard which I do I hold myself to a
high high standard and I gotta make sure
that I uphold that and that's a big
thing for me is being a guy that you
know ups hold himself to a high standard
and never you know letting guys like him
get under your skin you know because
that's bullcrap standing back left
Martin Z Johnson the undefeated dream on
green in the past has called for the
term owners to be done away just because
it gives these people this owner
mentality is looking at players not as
people but as kind of assets with the
incident that took place yesterday do
you think that gives further credence to
what he's been saying as far as how
maybe owners see athletes just because
of the name that they're given yes
I mean not everyone not all of them but
certain certain was yes and and I could
say for sure that guy makes me feel like
that you know Mark Stevens name is makes
me feel like he's one of those guys and
you know dream on with that and I
remember saying that I believe it's true
you know it's definitely you know we
called the Board of Governors but you
know you know people in the world we
call it ownership but it should be
changed and a guy like that definitely
shows you know that's what he feels to
me Michael on the right Kyle Michael
range from Sports Net the how were you
able to kind of separate yourself in
that moment and and quickly get back to
what you're doing on the floor and when
did you begin to realize how big a
moment you were kind of got caught up in
I think
whatever happened happened and and I was
still job me I was serious I'm
took me a couple minutes to kind of
think was a foul the ball came in play I
was still think about it another thought
was called and I believe we called the
timeout and I was pretty upset and Mark
a soul and kind of came in today look
you know kind of come on we need you to
kind of come back you know kind of you
know they'll handle it and you know
Freddie and in a kowai knows guys Danny
kinda you know like don't try to come
back here we need you stay in his moment
and understand the situation that we
were in as a basketball game and that's
what we're is it's about it's about us
winning the basketball game it
definitely kind of brought me back
quicker in you know understand I didn't
realize you know I mean I knew it would
be a big deal but I didn't know would be
as big of a deal of him as him being a
part of the the group that you know
writes the checks and it makes it even
more of a place where he should know you
know this is what happens when you see
it course I you know there's a
possibility that a guy's trying to make
a hustle play if Mark Davis wasn't who I
think I would have saved it but you know
it just happens and you can't show you
mean do what you want and obviously you
did what he wanted to do at that moment
anyone to you know push me in you know
curse at me different topic would be
going in you know people come out to
Oracle you want to get one that's the
goal always on the road how how greedy
are you guys about an opportunity to get
to we got to go out there and do our job
we got to continue to be better as a
basketball group you know we watched
from this morning and we we found a lot
of mistakes that we made I think we got
to continue to just stay in a moment
continue to push the pace and continue
to play defense the way we know how to
play defense and try to and do what we
can do you know and control what we can
control
Tim standing back right Kyle Tim
Reynolds with the AP kind of a two
parter when LeBron came out earlier
today and said okay cool but don't stop
here as far as the reaction what did
that mean to you as far as that kind of
support and secondly for as angry as you
were last night is it kind of a
different anger today that you guys want
a Finals game at Oracle and you had 23
and
guys played great and this person's
actions have kind of become the story of
the finals at this point know one thing
about Brian he's always been activists
and and he's always been there but he's
he's unbelievable this and you know I
got a I sent a text a message to him he
sent one back and I and I thanked him
because he's one of the biggest you know
athletes and and most vocal guys that we
have out there and his his just how his
social activism is has been amazing and
he sticks up for his fellow players and
he always does the right thing and
that's the one thing about him he's been
doing the right thing in his whole
career and and it means a lot
it really does means a lot to be able to
have the support you know guy like him
and other other players also reaching
out and having support and it sucks that
this has to take the front page of you
know the kind of the finals you know
it's been a pretty it's been a fun
finals it's been a competitive finals
and it just really it really sucks that
this has to you know take part and had
to be a part of it for me you know this
would be my last you know time talking
about it and you know dealing with it
because it's it's it's here and it's now
and hopefully the NBA does more and
continue to move forward with this but
it sucks because you know at the end day
we just want to play basketball we're
playing basketball we're trying to win a
championship you know and our family and
our friends are you know supporting us
and watching us and our colleagues are
watching and you'd say this to it the
game takes a little bit of a backseat
because of this and this sucks but you
know we'll get back to you know we'll
have our conversations today about it
and hopefully the league does what they
support you know hopefully what they do
what I you know think they should do
hopefully and we'll get back in to focus
for the game tomorrow that person
reached out to you or me time to reach
out to you this far as you know no I
don't mean I don't think there's even
for me personally I have I don't know
him I don't care to know him he showed
his true colors at the time and you know
you show what you're really about at
that time in that moment
you know and that's not all you get you
get the reaction of everyone else saying
this that the other you know that's kind
of the whole let me know you show what
you really are you know for me if they
happen to me hey you okay good you know
and move on but at that moment you heat
a moment you know when the pressure and
the tightness is only show who you
really are
thanks Kyle Gregory Time magazine what
was your reaction when you found out
that mark Stephens the guy who pushed
you was an owner of a part owner of the
team unbelievable even worse even worse
I mean you should understand like you
know this is what happens you know it's
basketball I'm competing I'm trying to
save a basketball I'm trying to help my
team get a possession and it's just a
just sucks man just sucks that you got
people like that role in the Guardian I
said that you hope the league does what
you'd like them to do I'm curious what
do you want them to do first of all and
second of all you mentioned you thought
about your children Marc Gasol kind of
talked you down was there a moment where
that could have gone another way like
how did you kind of you know keep your
cool and restrain yourself I think what
I think and what I feel is a guy like
that shouldn't be a part of a shouldn't
be a part of our league being honest
that's my personal opinion that's just
how I feel and you know we've had
situations like this before and it's you
know the league's done the right thing
and and that's protecting their players
and protecting the image of the league
and and the second part yeah it could
have gone the other way it definitely
could have gone bad but you know I'm I'm
bigger than him as a person my kids are
more important to me than he is to me so
I got to make sure that I always you
know thankful my kids first and that's
what it's all about
last two in the back and then Phil here
in the front Cameron Buford here LA News
observer hey Kyle camuto's to you on
number one how you reserved how you
control yourself control your emotions
thank you congratulations on the W last
night thank you how can
clay wasn't played playing yesterday how
does Clay's absence impact the
performance yesterday and then what do
you think he's gonna be supposed to play
tomorrow what do you think clays how you
can impact the game tomorrow oh it takes
a takes an all-star NBA guy off the
floor that's best one it made Steph be a
lot more aggressive and still having 47
points doing everything he could
possibly do to help his team win the
game I think clay is gonna come out and
be aggressive and be himself the one
thing about clay he brings defense he
brings offense he brings just that that
extra swag that they have as a team as a
team and as an individual competitor
he's one of the toughest guys out there
Phil on the front hey Kyle Phil barber
Santa Rosa Press Democrat just to
clarify a couple points when you were
chasing that ball out of bounds and out
of bounds did one of the fans maybe the
woman slap or try to catch the ball or
something and go ahead I didn't see that
I hit the ball I don't literally I was
trying to just dive and save it and I
mean I made a good save it just happened
to hit the official that was Mark Davis
I was standing there and he was standing
out of Bounce so it was a good call by
him out of balance and then the other
thing you spent a good while during that
timeout talking to the officials what
were you advocating for at that time for
him to be gone I mean he shouldn't at
that moment
it should have been taken care of right
away you know I'm not I'm not - got us I
understand this and we are I love our
fans we have great fans but for you to
push me to curse at me and to say things
to me that's untolerable at all he
should not and at that moment I wanted
to be taken care of but you know we're
discussing it now you know hopefully
things you know get taken care of the
you know I appreciate the Warriors again
for the apology the NBA for stepping up
and you know we'll see what happens from
there thank you